Hi, I'm Kirill.
And I want to tell a few
stories about the dm package
and show recent developments.
In a nutshell, dm helps when
we have multiple tables in R.
Some call this a
relational data model.
So we had computers
for sale in the '50s.
We started to think about
databases in the '60s.
In 1970, Edgar Codd published
a relational model,
and this is way before I was
born and still in use today.
An example.
The points at the right
are energy consumers
in Switzerland, stored in rows
in the table at the left.
And there is a lot of detail
in all those related tables.
And this looks scary.
With our client,
we wanted to build
a Shiny app that
allows filtering across
all those related tables.
This shows the
Shiny app in action.
All we had back then was a tool
to visualize the relationships.
We did not have tools that
made the task less scary.
So we went ahead.
We implemented a routine
that did all those joins
and filters in
800 lines of code.
It worked, but it was tedious.
It was difficult to
maintain, it was error-prone,
and we thought we can
do better than that.
And that's how dm was born.
With the dm package,
the filtering logic
was reduced to a
variant of this.
So from 800 down to six.
And the best thing is, if
the data model changes,
the code stays the same.
I call it a success.
Others call it a success, too.
It's amazing.
It's a treasure.
It's a lifesaver.
Thanks, Garrick.
Thanks, Hadley.
Thanks, Nils.
Thanks to everybody who filed
issues, who contributed code
to the package.
You are awesome.
Best thing is we are
on CRAN in version 1.0.0.
R-universe and GitHub as well.
So if you want the
latest and greatest,
you may want to go
to R-universe.
If you don't want to mess
up your local installation,
click this Posit Cloud button.
This gives you a... well,
should I say RStudio Cloud?
At some point, this will change.
IDE in your browser
with everything
installed so you can just test.
So there is no excuse
to not try it today.
All right.
Some people are wary
about dependencies.
We are not among those people.
So in fact dm
wouldn't have been
possible without all those
great packages we depend upon.
Without R Core, without
tidyverse, without igraph.
Thanks, Gabor.
Without well, everything.
Thanks. This is us.
And I always wanted
to bring this,
but I'm repurposing this today.
So we're talking
about multiple tables.
So which of these tools has a
concept of an active dataset?
Right, you start a
program, you open a file,
and this is your data set
and you work with it, right?
It is one car, one data set,
many cars, many data sets.
In R, we don't have
the active data set.
That's a good thing.
It took me a while
to realize there's
a difference between data
for analysis and data
cleaning, data management.
So for analysis,
all we really want
is tidy data: rows, columns,
cells with atomic values,
everything lined up cleanly
ready to put into our model.
Except there is
duplication in those
highlighted parts at
left, and we can't
have that for data management.
We can't have that
for data cleaning.
This leads to problems
further down the road.
So if we try a different
approach, wide form,
this is better.
There is no duplication except
that those beautiful column
names,
make me want to turn
this into long form
the first time I see it.
So we want multiple
tables we need often.
Multiple tables
and we want dm
because that's what
dm is doing.
If you have more than one table,
dm makes your life easier.
We are in the database session.
So many of you will know about
primary keys and foreign keys.
This is just to make very sure
we're all on the same page
very briefly.
The data set we saw in
the previous slides could
be decomposed into two tables.
Measurements at the left,
entities at the right.
So multiple measurements
correspond to a single entity.
The entities have a primary key.
The ID column, the measurements
have a foreign key
also in the ID column
linked to the entities.
And in fact, this is what a
dm object contains: tables.
This could be local data frames
or lazy tables on the database
with the dbplyr package.
Maybe arrow also works, but
I'm not sure we need it.
More on that
on the last slide.
We have primary keys ID and
we have foreign keys that
link tables together.
That's a dm object, but.
Do we really need a new package?
For 2 tables, for 5 tables.
Even for 10 tables.
Just worked before.
Will it actually make
your life easier?
Will it integrate into
your existing workflows?
Will it help you in your work?
And I believe the
answer is yes, yes, yes.
And I'll show you how.
So this is a very new thing,
a Shiny app we have built.
And the team at cynkra
helped a lot with that.
So thanks here for
all the support
I got when preparing this.
This is the AdventureWorks
data set
if you're familiar with that.
And that's the
Shiny connection.
So if we start
from the database,
we can with pointing
and clicking,
select the tables we care about.
We can create code.
That we can run immediately,
we can store it in an R script,
we can put this into a function.
So David here will talk
more about how to turn this
into a real R package.
But for us, this kind of works.
So you run this Shiny app once.
This is pretty much
like the RStudio/Posit
IDE Import Assistant.
It will give you code
that you can reuse.
This is just a summary.
So selecting tables
gives you code
which you can copy to
your console at once.
For the data frames use case,
when you start with data frame,
data frames don't know
about primary, foreign keys.
They have just rows and
columns, so we have to teach
dm what those keys are,
and we can do this as well
with the Shiny app.
So we're selecting
the tables, we're
selecting the columns
that constitute
the primary keys and
the foreign keys,
and we get an instant
preview in the diagram.
Same here we get the code.
Plus, we can also
experiment with colors.
I find this very helpful in
guiding the eye in the more
complex data model.
There is an undo
function if we mess up.
If you're satisfied,
the copy to console button
will give you the code
for this data model
from your data frames.
So that's new.
That's in dm version 1.0.1.
And yeah.
To sum up.
Works for
databases, for tables on the
database, works for data frames.
Try it out.
In our consulting
work, we are using
dm, well, you saw the
expression whenever
we have more than
one table, dm
is just the basic
thing that we do.
We used it to help
with a Shiny app
that handles contracts.
So, this is a situation where we
have for
a contract partner.
First stage, contracts at the
level of individual countries.
And then the second stage, we
would pool contracts together
to get an overarching
query for this customer.
And this shows the database
UI that we have contributed.
We have projects,
quote, family quotes.
And this maps to this
data model that we
have designed with
the dm package
and applied to the database
as soon as we are ready.
And we could also
continuously update it
because the data model
is specified in code.
So the first stage is everything
that's orangish at the bottom.
And what we can do
with dm very easily
for a specific quote which we
identify with the primary key,
the quote ID, we can
get all the related
data in one swoop
with the dm package.
Load it locally.
Update what we need based on
the input from the Shiny app.
Put it back to the database.
So this is create, read, update,
delete for you in Shiny.
Made easy with the dm package
on a complex data model.
For data analysis.
So this is the
noisy flight data.
We use it throughout the
documentation of the flights
of the dm package.
If we aggregate
the flight table,
let's say we group by origin,
summarize, compute number
of flights per origin airport,
or let's say mean arrival delay.
What happens is
the result is a table that
is conceptually linked.
With the airports table.
So this group by, summarize,
creates an implicit foreign key
into the airport table because
the data in the origin column
maps to what's been
in the airport.
And this link is
useful if we want
to later bring in
details from airports
or from other related
tables maybe not shown here.
How does the dm package
make it easy
to keep track of your keys?
We have a new feature.
We call it deconstruct,
reconstruct.
You can go from a dm
object, from a data model
to individual tables
that still know
about their primary
and foreign keys.
I'm not going to
tell you how, but we
can talk about this later.
We can apply data
transformations
on those separate
tables with dplyr, tidyr
or whatever works
for you, and we
can put this back
into a relational data
model as a dm object.
A bit of code.
So the new dm_deconstruct
function
There's nothing
except printing code.
So from a dm object that
has tables, primary keys
and foreign keys.
It will give you a code that
gets you those separate tables.
Which you then can compute on.
So keyed = TRUE is
kind of the key here.
The constructor on
those objects will
result in an object
that still has
all those primary and
foreign keys in place.
And this also works when
we have analyzed the data.
So here the new table will
contribute one primary
key, one foreign key.
I'm very excited
about this feature.
We had a similar concept
called zooming before,
but this of course
doesn't integrate as well
with existing workflows.
So I think this is a
step towards helping
adapt dm to
existing codes so
that you could
benefit from dm even
if you're not starting
on the green field.
That's what the resulting
dm object looks like.
I've had this before.
Why one data model?
Why just one data model?
We can do more.
So this is an example
from another project
with another customer.
The notes,
the boxes in this diagrams
are whole data models.
The arrows represent
data transformations.
This is an ETL process.
Extract, transform, load.
Targeting whole
data models, data model objects,
whole data set going from
data set to data set,
giving better guarantees,
moving to the right
in terms of data quality.
Data integrity.
And so forth.
We don't have a specific
framework to do this.
This is right now all custom.
This could be a blog post,
but we have a pretty good idea
how to do this because there
is an inherent chicken and egg
problem here.
When populating a
database, we first
need to create a structure.
The tables with the columns
and the relationships
in an empty form before
we can fill them.
And how do we know
this structure?
So the dm_ptype function
helps us, which
gives us the prototype of
the dm object.
Meaning?
tables and relationships
minus the data,
which we then can write to
the database and populate.
I want to spend the last
few minutes on a new idea
that didn't make
it into dm 1.0.0
but that we are
also excited about.
Normalized data has
been around for ages
and will stay around. At the
other end of the spectrum.
We have deeply nested data,
so when you query a web API,
typically what you get
is JSON deeply nested
and somewhere in the middle
we have nested tables.
With the tidyr package
think of nest and unnest, pack and unpack.
Arrow has great
support for this in.
In their data format.
And what we can
do in the dm today
is get from normalized data from
a dm object to nested tables.
To a single nested
table and back.
More or less losslessly,
more or
less in all cases.
We're working on that.
But this idea looks
very appealing,
in particular with
the very nice
tibblify package, which I
think is really underrated.
We can go from deeply nested
to nested tibbles
in a controlled way,
and the way back to
JSON is understood.
So with all those bits and
pieces in place, I hope,
very soon to be able to present
a way to seamlessly move
between all those formats.
So so this all of this becomes
one, and perhaps nested tables
are our middle ground because
this would allow us
to go back to one single table.
That's just easier than
all those boxes and arrows.
We are cynkra.
The team, as I
said, helped a lot.
Preparing the Shiny app,
making sure this all works.
Thanks here.
We're very excited
to be a sponsor here.
If you have detailed questions
or would like to chat
or would like to have one
of those cheat sheets here.
They're also new, come by.
Happy to talk or happy
to take questions here.
Thank you.